Valerie Ayer,
who is our smooth head,
uh, for the Europeans,
for the majority, uh
Welcome.
So remember her name,
Valerie Ayer,
because she is going to be our
head of pump throughout this campaign.
The stakes are major,
of course.
You see,
in a few hours,
we will be able to vote,
uh,
via the mirror,
theconstitutionnalisation of the ivg.
Do we want to in Europe
to have a majority that is
progressive on these essential fights,
for example,
women's rights?
On the contrary,
1 reactionary majority
who would come
create retreats for women's rights.
This is one example among many others.
We also go out
of the agricultural show that took place
all this week,
do we want
more Europe
to ensure that there is no circumvention of the law,
to guarantee Easter for our farmers?
Where do we want less Europe?
But outright those who say
need to export at all
to their own
that we are lucky to have 1 agriculture that is exported ?